so
um
this is uh
uh then um
uh time to work hard problem too but i
had a
just one thing on the way home from
class on thursday that i thought i'd
mention
just as a corollary of a work on problem
one suppose we had base 100 and we were
trying to find
sorted squares in base 100 can somebody
give me an interesting example of an
infinite class of sorted squares base
100.
yeah right anything for base 10 is going
to be sorted for base 100 except that in
groups of two
it doesn't go the other way you might
have a something in base 100 that was
like repeated 25 25 25 or something like
that but
but
in in particular
there will be one in base 100 that
starts out say three and then has a
whole bunch of 33s
and then has a 36
and then a bunch of 66s
followed by 67
and similarly with you know without this
36 in here without this three in there
and so this shows uh
um a class of
of uh uh you know
of things where where you have uh an
extra digit in between the two
repeating sequences as well as an extra
one in front i mean that just and and
similarly we'd get
a base a thousand and so on so so you
can see the uh
uh as the base gets more composite we
get more
chances for
for these funny patterns and
it would
it would be an interesting conjecture
though to
or to
maybe a doable problem to figure out
what bases have no repeated patterns at
all
for example
maybe a prime plus one
would have no repeated patterns who
knows
but that's uh that's just a
final footnote for problem one okay now
now problem two i'm not sure exactly
where it's going to lead us of course i
never know but the
uh
a priori the name of the game seems to
be
um
uh something about probability
and something about
um interactive interactiveness or
whatever the the noun is interaction
and
internship whatever the word is so so uh
so making interactive making a a
a a program so that up so that uh a
human
intuition can combine well with uh
with
coat with
some kind of statistical routines
that'll that will sort out hypothesis
efficiently so that the person doesn't
have too much to do driving the program
but i but a human being is really
an essential part of the loop i i
believe uh
i constructed a solution to cipher
number one
that
that uh
had only ascii codes in it
but made absolutely no sense at all
um
just just to you know so so the there's
somehow there's one sensible solution i
think only one
uh very much so
only one sensible solution to each of
those ciphers
okay so let's uh let's start out with
probability of thinking a little bit
about probability and um
and first of all i wonder if if anyone
let's let's look at the at the kinds of
permutations that are represented by
this this uh f
and to make the problem simpler let's uh
let's let's restrict ourselves to
permutations of 10 elements instead of
256. so let's try to figure out first of
all how many
f's there are that would take the digits
zero to nine into the digits zero to
nine with those properties that are that
are the key to our our
decryption so that says that f of f of x
has to be equal x
and f of x is unequal x
isn't it sterling
which sterling number square
this one
this with five something like that
okay now this is um
this is the uh uh does
anyone else know that
this this notation for sterling numbers
these are
the uh
um
the the square bracket sterling numbers
are
represent the number of permutations
with 10 this would represent the number
of permutations on 10 elements that has
five cycles
people know what a cycle of a
permutation is
everybody knows that right don't be
don't be embarrassed if you don't know
the cycle five cycles have been in five
cycles
five
cycles
yes that means that so so this is the
number of permutations so for example
um let's take a simpler case four two
the number of permutations that have
that have um
two cycles uh the permutations would be
like one two three four as an example it
fixes one
and takes two to three three to four and
four to two
uh and then the opposite one
two four three and then there's several
more
similar ones where 2 is fixed in and 1 3
4 1 4 3 and so on
and then there are um
let's see to get two cycles then we also
have the cases one two three four one
three two four
and one four two three
so there's two there's another one with
two fixed another one with three fixed
and two with four
all together one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven
and so i think the sterling number four
two
what do you call it four
i don't remember the
slang for it even anymore
um i think we call it four bracket two
or something like that is uh is is
eleven i guess
if i haven't missed any
um
well these aren't all
all of that kind of um
the number of pairings so that would
just yeah
like these are the ones we're trying to
count yeah so um i guess it'll be 10
factorial over
um two q to the fifth divided by five
factorial okay now ten to the ten
factorial over two to the fifth
isn't just interesting divided by five
factorial is andy's
i claim although he might deny it
now someone else says ten choose two
um
is another
another
claim that it might be the number of
that's the number of pairs
choose 2 times 6
10 is 2 times 8 choose 2
because that's just choosing how to
choose 2 elements
and
another suggestion is that we first
we first choose a pair
and then we have eight elements that
haven't been chosen yet and so we we
have that many ways to choose the next
pair
and so on
and so on and so on
um
and that would give us ways of choosing
pairs now why do you say that this has
to do with pairs both of you first of
all
um
i mean that's i think fairly quickly we
ought to make it on the table are we i
think it should be 10 to 5 into 5
factorial
and we got another one is 10 5
times 5 factorial
or into what is integer
that's multiplication yeah okay
um
okay so this so we know that
permutations can always be represented
as cycles
and and there is no one cycle because of
this condition but everything is a two
cycle and so it's got to be represented
in terms of two cycles that's the
that's the thing and now we have some
competing formulas here
um let's try to represent these in uh
in factorials and see what we get for
this one this is 10 factorial over
over 2 factorial 8 factorial and then 8
factorial over 2 factorial 6 factorial
will be a lot of
cancellation um
and i think i'll make it just in time
here
two factorial two fact
tutorial
and then now this one is one
so so that can so we get everything
cancelling
and uh
looks like 10 factorial over two
to the fifth all right
but but uh this one is also divided by
five factorial this one here says ten
factorial over
over five factorial but we have a half
we need a two to the two
to get the five factorial on the second
one you
you just have to build that number
permutations of five objects because
when you pick the pairs you could depict
them in any order okay right so i first
i first pick a pair and then i have then
i pick another pair but but uh the same
i get the same f
uh if i pick the second pair first
instead of the first pair and so there's
a factor of five factorial so this this
seems to be a believable number here
and
there and this this number by the way is
is a
multinomial coefficient that's sometimes
written
10
um
2 2 2 2
2.
there's a number of ways of
of
taking 10 elements and putting them into
five groups of five uh but that's that
includes the order of the five groups of
five so if we if we divide by five
factorial then we then we exclude the
order
now let's see if we can apply this
formula
to uh to to to a method that would
generate one of these at random what
would be a good way to
to generate a random f
uh so that each of these guys is equally
likely
you know it would id ideally it would
give you also a way to to generate a
random f
for the uh
for size 256.
how do we do that
choose an element
at random and then um
we have to have to remove them as we go
okay so so we start out and we choose a
number between
0 and 9
equally likely and then we remove it
and we choose a second number
and uh that becomes the
thing to pair with it right
okay
so let's see i don't have a
random number generator but uh let's uh
let's use the digits of pi uh whenever
we need a random number
uh
people know pi to uh
enough places now i have a rhyme
assisting my feeble brain
but it's
it's some time resisting
okay
that might be enough to get us around
around random permutation okay now let's
imagine writing a computer program that
wants to quick generate one of these
just this is a quick question it doesn't
really solve problem two but it gets us
into a little spirit of computer
programming so we're gonna have to
remove
elements from the permutation as we as
we as we get them uh
but we'd like to get random random uh
pairing somehow by the way what's the
difference between this and just
generating a random permutation i mean
suppose you know the first first you
choose a
first you choose a number between zero
and nine and then you choose then you
remove it and you choose a number
between you know the remaining nine guys
remove that and and remaining eight ties
and so on that's that just gives us a
random permutation it's as if we we took
a random permutation
and then decided that the first two
elements of that permutation are going
to be paired together the next two are
going to be paired together and so on
okay so so in a way we're saying that uh
that one way to get a random f is to is
to have a random permutation is to
imagine that we have five boxes
and two two um
slots in each box and we put a random
permutation in these ten slots
then
we let this be the function
and uh and uh the
uh the fact that we get the same
function by by five five factorial ways
to to uh move these boxes around
and uh by
we have got two ways to interchange the
elements in each of the boxes again
giving the same function that that's
another way to prove that we've gotten
um
that many
f's because uh 10 factorial ways to to
put a permutation in there and then and
then uh two to the fifth times five
factorial equivalent functions from
every every such way and that that works
in general if you want to say how many
ways are there to have
a certain number of one cycle certain
number two cycle certain number of three
cycles and so on
um you you write boxes out with the with
the right number of slots in it and then
you put a random permutation in those
boxes
then you uh you divide by
the uh
the product of the
uh you know you have factorial
like suppose i wanted to say a1 one
cycles
a2 two cycles
and so on
then the
the final total is going to be
n
which is equal to n factorial that's
n is equal to
a1 plus 2a2 plus and so on
n factorial divided by
and then
we have
inside of each
inside of each cycle we have a cyclic
permutation
of that we can do
so each cycle of length four can appear
in four different equivalent ways
um so we have to divide by
one to the a1 2 to the a2
and so on and then we also have to
divide by a1 factorial a2 factorial and
so on
in order to consider interchanging
different boxes that's the
generalization of this thing but let's
let's just try to compute a random
permutation now
on um on a digit zero to nine well we
start with
with an array that contains zero to nine
and at the beginning we choose a random
number from zero to nine
and it's three
um
so three is our first element of our
permutation
now let's what's a convenient way to uh
to remove it from the set and
and continue uh uh generating from the
remaining eight
uh
move the others over
take off
take it out and move the others over is
one way to do it and to swap with the
last one is another way what would be
the bet what would what would be the
winning
way
i mean yeah one one idea is to is to go
from from this to zero one two four five
six seven eight nine
um and that re that means that we have
to move
move about half the elements on the
average it's easier it's easier to swap
because we don't even need to swap this
okay so so so uh
you could put you could you could put
this element three off on the side
and put nine in here in place of it
and fill the hole that way because we
don't really care that these numbers are
in increasing order it doesn't
it doesn't hurt us because we're going
to we're trying to generate a random
permutation anyway so
the rest of the problem we're going to
get a random permutation of these
remaining nine guys there's no reason
why we have to have them in any
particular order any convenient order
will will be as good as any okay so
three is the is the first element of our
random permutation in this way and then
we we look for a random number between
zero and eight
and it's one
so out comes one eight goes in here
and the next one is four
zero one two three four
interesting random permutation that
we're getting here
i've always felt that that
the most random permutation of four
elements is three one four two because
that's pi to
two three places
for three decimal
um
now um uh you know of course if we get a
number that's too big we just
can reject it and move on or something
like that
but i've used up this one now and that's
going to tell me to choose 8 and so on
um
incidentally uh
if i didn't want to keep these in a
separate array where could i put them
at the end i could just put them back in
the at the at the end of the thing and
uh
and later on okay now this process we
might as well continue it out to the
bitter end just to to make clear what we
what what our grade permutation is going
to be zero one two three four five
um
now nine we wanted to generate a a
random digit zero to four at this point
and we got a nine
so we could either throw it out or we
could
we could wrap around and say that this
is zero one two three four five six
seven eight nine so let's do that
uh zero one two
um
uh
six
of
zero one two three four five
six
it's okay we'll take the zero
i have to do that i i have to do that in
some way that i'm
that i'm not
biasing it towards low digits
for example if i was trying to get a
random digit be
zero up to five then i wouldn't want to
go past
i wouldn't want to go after five to six
seven eight nine because i have no way
of getting
uh the four and five again on the second
cycle on the second lap
that's uh but i i i've only got this
source of random digits so it's a funny
situation
uh
now
five is zero one two three four five so
that would be here so so that's our
that's a rent this is a random
permutation of of ten elements and then
we
we can say that we can make a function f
out of it by
by saying that three and one go together
four and eight go together five and
seven go together two zero and six and
nine so
okay
so that's
um
idea that we have
of
that many out of the sea how about how
many is this just for curiosity 10
factorial about 3 million
um
i think
for the 31 million what is what
it's
i forget it it starts with a three but i
can't remember if it's a 30 million or 3
million
excuse me
three million six hundred and
twenty eight thousand
and something
divided by 32
and then times five factorial that one i
remember is 120. so so so re so roughly
speaking we got 3 times 10 to the 6th
divided by
3 times 10 to the fourth
and so it looks like about 100
altogether is that right
at least that's what i got 945
okay so what did i so maybe so this
i think this must be 36 mil this much i
must be off by
in in 10 fact 10 factorial let's see
okay 10 factorial is 30 million instead
of 3 men
i don't remember anymore
um
everybody knows is 105
so uh
so it's it's nearly a thousand okay so
yeah it's about a thousand
uh
of these and of course for uh uh for
256 uh
there's going to be lots and lots and
lots more but um
so we can't simply try them all and
and
see which one works
now suppose that i had a
message a um
a a ten digit message um like three one
four one five nine two
let's take the digits we haven't looked
at yet
three five eight nine seven nine
three
um
well
it doesn't have to be pi
one two three four five six seven eight
nine okay
now
this would be some kind of a random
um a random number of times to use this
function
uh
how many of these cycles actually get
used
for example this would get ins this
would get mapped into by that
permutation we get going to into
three we go to one five to seven
seven to five
one two three eight goes into four
nine goes into six
two goes in now zero seven goes into
five
okay so
so uh we used this we used three one
four eight five seven
two zero six oh yeah we used them all
in that particular
case
uh but um
the question i wanted to raise now is uh
if i have a random permutation of these
900 and some
what's the what's the chance that
what's the chance that a particular
cycle say would never be used at all
so i have a particular cycle
let's call it a
b
what's the chance that i have a message
in which
in which a b never gets used to it never
appears at all in the uh
in the uh
in the encoding
okay um
andy
let's try to figure out how many
messages there are that don't
use the
the the cycle a b
if nothing is that cycle that means two
digits can't be used that's right right
so we've got a we got a con how many
messages are there of length 10 let's
say that don't use a and b
so that would be just um
eight to the ten right and then the
total number of messages is 10 to the
10.
so 8 to the 8 10 to the 10th is the
chance that
a particular cycle is not used
okay
so um
so if we if it doesn't depend on on a or
b of course and uh
uh
now so this is the chance that a cycle
is not used
uh
and uh
uh what's the expected number of cycles
that are not used
okay there uh for every each one of
these cycles
i have
certain i have this probability that
it's not used right so now the expected
number of cycles not used
in the average if we if we average over
all messages
uh and we and we for each message we say
how many cycles did you
didn't you use
uh there will be some messages that
you know okay uh
just want to get into the
the kind of thing what do you think my
marianne
mike says they're not we can't add in we
can't add non-independent probabilities
when we're taking expected value
the expectation here yeah you can add
the averages but you can't you can't add
you you can't uh add other things but
but averages you can't however
the average of
of two correlated events if you know a
certain event
e1
and it has a certain average m1
and if you have another event e2 and it
has its average m2
uh even if e1 and e2 are are
completely determine each other
the average of of the of the two
quantities uh is m1 plus m2
so we so we are allowed to add when we
calculate
averages in fact that's the that's a
that's a great simplification
about average is why it's why people
like to calculate averages i guess it's
one of the
because it's easier to calculate maybe
the average doesn't mean anything but
it's easy to calculate and it's nice to
have numbers
so um
so with that clue saying that that the
the number that the in other words if
let's let's justify that again in a
suppose you spoke we wrote out all 10 to
the 10th messages
and we know that eight to the tenth of
them don't involve three one
okay so we put a check mark on those
eight to the tenth guys
saying those are
here's a cycle you know a check mark or
a or maybe we put a
a chip on each one of those
so if the message doesn't use three one
we give it a chip
uh and so if we've paid out eight to the
tenth chips
now
similarly for 4 8 we look at all the all
of the messages that don't contain 4 8
and we put chips on those we could pay
out another 8 to the 10th chips
and similarly for 5 7 2 0 6 9 how many
chips have i paid out
uh and then i divide by ten to the tenth
to get the average number of chips paid
out
uh so
marianne how are you saying
but um
isn't there a problem because if if you
check all all the ones that
uh don't use the pair three one
and then check the ones that don't don't
have the pair four eight you might check
again
the same
um yeah i'm asking for a sim i'm asking
for the average number of of things not
used i'm not asking for
the total number of things not used
or i'm not saying how many are there
that don't use
that don't use exactly two i'm saying on
the average how many are are unused
um so if some if uh
if yeah you know that's the same as the
question saying if i if i took all 10 to
the tenth messages
and i counted all chips on all those
messages
divided by 10 to the 10 that's the
that's the number i'm getting i'm trying
to get the average number of chips
on a message
so so i know how many chips i would have
paid out in the whole in the whole uh
if i had all 10 to the 10 messages i'd
i would pay out 8 to the 10 chips for
the first pair plus 8 to the 10th for
the second and so on so i get
so so the final answer is
five times five times eight
eight to the tenth divided by ten to the
tenth yeah
okay
now in similarly in our in our problem
we have a random
f
um
and by the way i can assure you that i
did choose f in exactly this kind of a
way i generate a random permutation and
then i decided that
those would be the the two cycles
um
if we have a random f
then how many um
cycles of f would we expect would never
occur
on the average
like 255 yeah yeah
128 times 128 is the is the number of
cycles right times
the probability
that the number of messages that that
don't use a particular cycle
254
256 okay right
now that's the
average number of cycles that that we
aren't going to hit it
at all in the in in a message that's
what the message is
is random random yeah and if it's
english text or pascal text it's not
random
it's been uh it's been skewed by uh
by adding k
uh
um but that's all we know right
but also it's been skewed by being
sampled from the english language
yeah
yeah so so that's right you start with
with uh with something from english text
um
that okay let's let's work on the first
assumption we have random and then talk
about the sku from english that's a very
good point but i want to first get this
formula let's let's
can we ca we estimate what this is
without
without a calculator how can we how can
we figure out what is so so anyway we
this is a just a suppose
for example
um this would this would arise in the
cryptography problem in the following
sense suppose that somebody even told
you the the the message
uh somebody
somebody told you what the
what the whole message was but you were
supposed to figure out f
because really um uh uh
the the important thing was that f had
already been used to encode lots of
other messages
and so we really wanted to know f so we
could put put it into a machine and
grind out the key to lots of other
messages but we we happen to know this
this message
you know somebody screwed up and and
kept
kept a copy of his f of his file in both
uh plain form and in siford form and so
we and so we found that and so we got a
rosetta stone that told us um what the f
was but how many of how much of f would
would not would still not have been used
uh in this case if uh if we assume uh
that things were random if we assume
that the that the original text was
random
and this is the
the this is the average number of cycles
that haven't been used yet
uh but let's estimate that is there an
easy way to calculate that
take the two
i mean
256 minus two right okay so that's one
minus two over 256 to the that's one
minus
seven
this is what one minus two to the minus
seven
right
one minus two to the minus seven
raised to the 256. yeah
yeah there's an easy but from here i
would i would go to a
minus square i i would consider this to
be 1 over 2 to the n raised to the n
yeah which is when n is large because of
because yeah okay
so which is very close to
e to the minus 2.
all right so
uh
now we have to know what e to the minus
two anyway so it's
it e
at least we can calculate that guy out
um
with a calculator we could get e to the
minus two right or you know so so let's
let's see what that is that's uh
does anybody have a calculator
no
what
it's about seven point seven and a half
for e squared okay so uh so that's uh
ten
three-fourths times
10 so now we've got 3 40 so that's 40
thirds it's about 13.
you want to take 128 over 7.5
128. yeah right
um well let me just yeah so 128 over
7.5
which is
which is three-fourths of 10.
if that helps any
so that's uh 250 whatever
so that's about
80
no
256
25 over three it's about eight huh
so
so 128 e d squared is is more like
more or less eight or something like
that but what do you think
no
16.
oh yeah
okay it's about 16. okay okay
okay sorry so we've got 16
uh roughly 16 of the pairs won't be
exercised you know
in the message uh on the average
what
17
even 17 i think
okay
yeah
in actuality
yeah that
that number is much too small
for the text that we were given i found
that only
i think 110 of the
pairs were used
in the second message
and actually i didn't make a count for
the first message 110 out of 128 is all
but 18.
128 pairs and
and uh
so this all right okay right so that is
about right
and uh but you but that's a good point
we have we have the messages we know
exactly how many pairs are actually used
in those messages
um
no you don't you have to decode it then
you know oh
oh you've decoded it yeah
well
okay anybody doesn't have a partner yet
so now in the
okay so let's see yeah you say we don't
know
uh
and how many pairs that have been used
of course until we've decoded that's
right we only know how many different uh
uh
how many different values of of uh
uh
like instead of working with pairs we
know how many of these these guys have
actually
been there like since three
or one we would know if it was used but
we wouldn't know if three and one are in
or in a
uh
the same pair yeah
okay so so uh uh at least by this
argument if we had if we had all the
plain text and if we had a random
situation we would expect
uh to get 100 uh
roughly 111 out of 128 pairs on the
average
now
um
let's let's see
you raise the question about what if we
start out with some
with some very biased uh messages
um
uh about the about the but the f was
chosen at random but the messages were
non-random
so in this case we
we consider
the uh
a particular message let's say only one
message
um but we choose f at random and then we
ask the same question how much how many
of the pairs of f
would not be used at all in this message
um
is that is there any meaning to that
all the same character repeated yeah
okay so the message
if the message
is is uh is very uh
if the message consists of all zeroes
then um
we get quite a different answer than if
the message is zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine
right so what really it's
involved here is uh
is that um we
if we have to know how many digits how
many different
digits there are in the message and if
we know how many different digits there
are in the message
then we can determine how many uh what
the chances are of the uh
that we're going to hit that part that
much of the of the f function
um
and uh so so you can you could look at
at the messages that we have in in
problem
in problem two
and uh
figure something like that out so let's
let's let's uh
let's suppose we take the second
ciphertext
um
does anybody have a copy of it here
okay now
what i'll write okay now how can we
figure out how many different uh values
of f have been used
in otherwise the ciphertext starts out
102
198
003 and it ends up with 185
now now if we're going to convert this
into
plain text
we have to add
add k to c sub k and apply f
and then um
and then subtract k
now
uh
but but uh how many different values of
x
for how many different values of x is f
of x going to be calculated well we find
that by adding
right but by by changing this uh
you know this is still 102 but this one
it goes to 199 this one goes to
005
and the last one will go to 184.
so if we look at that
at that form of the other numbers
uh and then that will tell us how many
different x's there are that for which f
of x uh is relevant in this problem
um now if that that's so that's not
going to be 256 probably it's going to
be
something like
uh
well 256 times
e inverse so probably we'll lose about
that many of them so it's about one
tenth huh
a little less than one tenth about one
we lose about nine
nine guys
oh two seven
oh wait that's no 130. i mean
if we lose uh roughly
that divided by 2.7 so
looks like uh
maybe 90 or something like that so
there'll be
170 whatever of these uh all these
different numbers
here for which f
is um going to be calculated
now if f has been chosen at random
then we could work out how many of the
of the of those
functions
how many
of them
avoid a particular pair in in f so
let's just that won't take long let's
just finish it suppose there were
suppose there were m different things
there say m is a think of m is about 170
or something like that there are m
different things here
and uh we wanted to to to count how many
of the functions f
for a particular random cycle a a b how
many um
of the
f's um
uh wait a minute if a b
either has
well it has both of its elements in
there or not or none of its elements in
there
uh
yeah we could work this out but i'm not
sure it would lead us anywhere for the
problem too so
so unless it's real easy i don't
i don't want to pursue it
now i guess the main the main point here
is that
is that
if we do need to
estimate the success of some kind of an
attack then then probability theory
comes in and uh
but but there are infinitely many
questions of probability that we could
ask and and uh we should probably
restrict ourselves to the ones that
relate most closely to our
our problem so
so i think um
anyway uh we can as
we can assume
it'll be
reasonably close to
reasonable to say that there's a fairly
substantial part of f will not know at
all
but we'll know most of f and and
and uh
any any kind of a method that that
that relies on
on
something that where f is almost all
known or something that that's sort of
out of the question for this problem
uh us
one of the things i guess to mention is
that the
the messages we have are 256 bytes long
that's not really an extremely long
message uh
uh
with with a code of this kind uh
um of course files tend to be
a lot longer than that 256 might seem
large in some sense but it was pretty
hard for me to write a pascal program
that was only 256
bytes long and it did anything
interesting at all because uh
already you write the word program and
left parenthesis and
and you've used up eight
eight bytes already and so you
you know you've got uh
you gotta say begin and end and a few
other things and pretty soon you're
you're out of you're out of space
so um uh yeah it's a fairly short
message
now we can look at our messages though
and and only the c k plus k
is ever relevant in the problem
so
um
although c k plus k appears in the
computer file
uh i don't see in our programs why
there's any reason to keep ck
anyway in the in memory because we're
going to adding
k to it every time we every time we look
at it so why not add k once and for all
and
and get that over with okay
um
on thursday mike
mentioned that the word program had this
very interesting
characteristic
um
uh
that
if you
if you add
to every letter
so you get p plus 0 r plus 1 and so on
m is equal to r minus 5 and so
and so
so these two values
will will lead under cyphermen to the
same
uh to the same thing
i guess the unix hackers know that
there's another word
in c programs that that has
that has this property does anybody
that can that's include
if uh if you have a c program that's
been in ciphered
and
and uh you
with this with this kind of method
uh and it has a lot of include
statements near the beginning of the
program
then um
let's see what what happens there n l
what did you say john
id
so that's 987654
yup
so d and e go the wrong way
uh
yeah but there are actually two of these
of these uh uh uh things in in the word
include now
the word
output has two
you say rightland
this is this is uh this is is there
anything that doesn't
actually i tried it on the english
dictionary afterwards how to
afterwards in the
in the unix english dictionary had some
kind of a
thing like this well that is
it can we account for that on some
on some probabilistic grounds
ing
you mean uh right there
and eb
why is it huh
i think the anglo-saxons
it must be
okay this could be easily broken what if
what if we took uh what if we had just
random uh text
uh with that it was a 26 letter alphabet
with their and and on and we we took a
a five letter work or you know maybe a
seven letter word
six we got longer words here string six
letter word
on a 26 letter alphabet
um
what would be the chances that we would
that we would find um
no hits at all let's say well let's see
that's that's a correlated
thing so let's just take the average
let's say the average number of hits
in a six-letter word on a 26-letter
alphabet
so
um
so what's the chance of a hit between
between letters one and two
unless we have a wraparound alphabet
yeah so let's look no it's not wrapping
around isn't it so so we get we get one
so um uh if the so if this first were if
this first letter is uh
if you know it's if it's uh a b where
these are
our variables that stand for letters
let's call it
x y i don't know
um maybe we ought to use numbers just if
we're gonna
but they take the
you know you always
when i was a student we always used to
wonder what was the limit of one as one
approaches two you know um
what
greek letters i'd say alpha beta good
point
okay so alpha beta
um
now if uh
uh if we know alpha then there are 20
there are uh
then then what's the chance that beta is
equal to alpha plus one and then and the
answer is uh
um
that it's either
it's either one out of 26 or a zero out
of 26 depending on whether this we got a
z here or not
right and so uh but sort of um
so it's 25
uh so let's see the chance of a hit is 1
out of 26 but it's actually
1 out of 26 times
25 plus 0 out of 26
times in the other case right so the
total is 25 over we get divided by 26 so
25 over 26 squared is the
is the exact probability that that
two
uh the first two
words will
will have it and for anything that's one
apart and for anything that's two apart
it's similar but we put a 24 there why
are you not using wraparound
oh why am i not using wraparound
because in in our problem
uh
we would we would assume that the uh
that the 26 letters
that are used in our text uh
uh that the next the next letter after
it is
uh
like you know if you have z
um
then then uh your chance of getting if
if you have a word that starts with z
your chance of finding a hit with that
and something else is nil in our in our
problem
oh why am i not using wrap around
because
in in our problem
uh
we would we would assume that the uh
that the 26 letters
that are used in our text uh
uh the next the next letter after it is
uh
like you know if you have z
um
then then uh your chance of getting if
you have a word that starts with z your
chance of finding a
hit with that and something else is nil
in our in our problems
right
now
we can't do anything with it yeah i'm
sorry i should i should subtract instead
yeah
and so because the the you know a minus
one is a left string quote and uh it
might be in a message
but um i'm assuming that uh
that we have only letters in this thing
so so for this for this purpose though
uh
the letter's only six long um
126 is a fairly good problem is a fairly
good
uh estimate of that probability
and uh
and it goes to the worst case where you
have something that are five apart to uh
that would go down to 20 over 26. it's
not it's nine
of one so it's it's close enough so
so uh um then if we have a six letter
word then we got one two three four five
six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15
uh potential
for this kind of a coincidence
and about 126
uh
in each
in each
which which would say that on the
average we would expect to have
um
half
uh half a chance of uh
of of a hit
and so
andy's uh uh
observation that the
english dictionary showed
about half of all of all words
would have this in it
is fairly consistent with randomness as
well as the the fact that eds and ings
are our common suffixes
that's a
that's it
yeah i've always you know there's a
there's a big need for for a dictionary
that has all the uh variant forms in it
uh if you're gonna do computer games
with uh
for almost all computer applications we
we uh
we want such dictionaries and uh um
our
former student frank liang
spent uh several months of time
preparing for his thesis by by
painstakingly putting in all these
variant forms by hand and
and uh i i remember the first time i ran
across this i uh
i
i was let's see i wanted to get a
complete list of uh
of five letter words
and my my first thought was okay uh to
get the
uh i if i had the
the uh
words um
in a dictionary without the variant
forms uh well i could
look for all the four letter words and
add s to get plurals and and uh verbs
with uh that end with s
um
and that would that would get me that
would get me the vast majority of these
things and so i started out
looking at the
at the list of five letter words with
this and with this uh uh hypothesis in
mind and right at the very beginning on
the first page i come to the word
abba kai
which is a counter example there's the
plural of
the you need the plural of a six letter
word in order to get a five letter word
uh and it was right at the beginning of
the dictionary so so i i realized that i
needed another
another method to get those
um well
well
let's hope somebody
get gives us more complete dictionaries
someday now that the uh um
um
i think they see what's the next
question i should ask maybe i should ask
you but i think the next question i'd
like to ask is suppose i were just
looking at a one letter
uh
uh one letter in a in a cryptogram and
see if and and try to see if there's a
chance we could even rule
uh you know
rule out um
one
one character suppose that i just take a
place
it random in my message and i say
is it possible
um that um
that p
uh 20
is equal to the letter a
and then uh
i took 20 and a it at random here but i
just want to i want to say you know
we might be able to root there's a
chance that we might be able to rule
this out without knowing very much about
um
about the problem except that we that
that
ascii code is involved in this function
f is a is a
product of two cycles so let's let's
let's just look at that suppose that i
have a one letter
a one letter uh crib i guess is what to
call
or a probable word of one letter and a
place and i ask for a specific place
could that letter go in that specific
place
well what would that imply
that would mean that f of
oh let's see a is um
97 okay
and so
so that would that would say that f of
117
is equal to
um whatever it is some number right
um let's take uh cryptogram number two
one two three
how did i do the 16 in a line so that 67
18 90 20 is 175
plus 20 is 195.
so i mean the exact numbers don't matter
but that let's suppose uh
so so suppose i suppose i would assume
that f of 117 is 195. can i
can i try to get any any um
any other consequences of this that
might lead to a contradiction
yeah
okay
um
well that gives you that that pair 117
195 it must be a cycle okay so that says
for example f of 195
equals
117.
you can go through the rescue message
and apply that
okay so now we've got um our ciphertext
of
c
k plus k
which should started out i had erased
here but it was 0 0
oh 102
191 199 and so on
well i i took the other one
no which one had i written on the board
i guess i took the second one yeah 102
199 and so on
um
and ending with uh
84. and now here we found then um
195
in this in this part in position 20.
and uh okay so we imagine that we have
that all out in the computer and now you
apply whatever you know about that in
this case just this just this pair
right so every time we've got a 117 or
195 sitting in there
then i know the other
the other guy so if there's a 117 over
there
then we know that this has to be 195
minus whatever in the plain text here
right here i've already assumed that
this goes to
117 minus 20 which is equal to a
so there's a possibility that so
in some other position you will get
you'll be able to plug function f
you'll subtract its position off to get
the plaintext character and find that
the plaintext character isn't one of our
legal characters that's right so the
chance of it being uh
the chance of it not being legal well
let's see how many legal are there
less than 100 it's a little 94 plus
94 visible characters in this space and
yeah 98
97 no 98 i think
yeah because the space in four and three
others is
uh so you got 98 characters
unless you believe me when i say there
aren't any right braces like curly
braces in there
let's uh
let's not use that fact
so
so
so we get
something like nine okay 98 out of 256
it's a 40 percent
uh chance of
that
that it'll be legal if there's another
117 in here
we have a fairly good chance of
you know sixty percent of the time
uh if there's another one in there sixty
percent of the time uh it'll be illegal
if this was if this was a bad if this
was a bad uh
assumption
okay so what's the chance that some of
these other words that some of these
other positions are going to have 195 or
117 in them
similar to the problems we've already
been doing so we're good at these by now
so
so uh we got 255
new new positions and uh each one of
them
we got a chance of uh
uh
the the chance that it's
that it's uh
so so let's say there's there's no hits
at all
um
that's um
that means that in all of those 255
places
we have
we have somehow stuck to 254 out of 256
of the
of the valid of the possible codes
if we're not using 1795 anywhere in here
that means that this is has gone on and
we know that this is approximately
uh
e to the minus two so
so um
uh
that's
that that's uh one
seventh you know fourteen percent so
so uh um
fairly small so the other eighty-five
percent of the cases then we get a
then we get a uh sixty percent chance of
ruling something out
and and we might even occur twice in
which case we have we have a better
you know still a better chance of
running something out
okay
the same thing with
uh
strings of characters
okay and consistency
just
of
the string
so
that's so you were so uh uh consistency
within a string now what do you mean by
that
if you have uh
if you have the whole string of
characters that you like
in other words p20 equals a p21 equals
equals
g something like that
it's possible that within this string
two of the characters may necessitate
that
uh the mapping be different
for to get the two characters in gas
positions
well so
i'm sorry i'm not sure
like for example uh
in the word program
yeah okay uh because because the r and
the m used to say map
if then we then we've got a real strong
condition yeah but let's suppose that we
don't have such a case that's why so
yeah that's what i so we we know that uh
that that if we got a if we got a two
two f's in the same word then we then
we're bound then then uh we've got a
real strong
uh
connection because these
these things have to
have to correspond um
117 is 195 so you might have a 195
somewhere else into the stream
okay there might be a 195 somewhere else
here i mean okay yeah if you're starting
out with the 195 and 170. basically 117
and 195 in the same string
in the same way in the same word yeah
then we would
then we would get uh
another case for example that that one
if
possibly a 117 would also be in the word
that's a different kind of a pattern
than the
then the 190 then in other words uh
because we're using the the bottom one
instead of the top one yeah in order to
get a in order to propagate uh
information right so um
now
um
what i was trying to do is push this to
from from a special cases um
uh is is uh is every method that we're
going to think of is it all
are there going to be ten different
tricks or is there sort of one very
general trick of which of which we're
seeing
we're seeing some instances of it
um
and uh and uh the most powerful thing
occurs when we have uh when we uh
like if we had a if we had a case where
there were two 195s in a row and we
would
i mean we would we would know that it
had to be a certain
a certain pattern right away from the
things like the word program however
uh
it looks like we have some
we let's see are there any other
deductions we can make
mike one very useful thing that can
happen is
in the second one you get the code 184
appearing two places very far apart you
say there's a 184 at the end
and also at character number 138 so
there's a 184 sitting here
and 138 and 255 are so far apart but in
fact there's only one possibility
oh right there
so that's it what are you saying that
this is this is in position 138 here and
this is in position 255 and they both
have had a 184
okay so now
that these these are going to have
some p sub k
plus k and this is going to have a piece
of cake this is going to be a piece of
138 plus 138
and this is a piece of 255 plus 255
and uh so the difference between
these
codes
um
is a hundred and twenty hundred and
seventeen there's only two characters in
there
and the ascii character set uh and and
so we gotta find two
two legal characters that are 117 apart
and so this forces
run to wrap around 117 or 130 yeah so
so um
okay so if there since the
legal codes are all less than 128
if they're less than 117 apart they both
it has to be a small one with a with a
big one the largest code is 126.
and uh subtract 117 from that you get
nine
which is just too small to be a line
so it has to be a null so so it tells
you
that uh instead so that that's another
kind of a observation and that uh
that this would
that this uh is forced to be a
uh
this one is forced to be in uh
that's a lyric
according to that observation
now
um
okay so that
now now the uh
the idea that was just brought up is
is uh
seems to me maybe a different flavor
from the from this idea of propagating
a lot of the values there how would we
formulate that
um in general
i suppose if you could think of it this
way
or maybe somebody else wants to
wants to to do this uh
uh
that is
we've got
these numbers 102 197
isn't it
198
sorry and so on
so what we have is uh
we we can make a chart uh
i'm not sure this is a good idea but
where we would
we would uh
go 0 to 255
and then we have
and here we try to to to to say f of 0 f
of 1
up to f of
255
and then here we say is it possible or
not what are the possible values of
these of these codes
and um
uh
for and what you what for example here
when we have f of 2 of
of 184
the possible values of f of 184
have to
be um
ascii code plus 138
and so the possible so uh
uh let's see if i put in
x's for for values that can't occur
uh none of these can occur until i get
to 138 is okay so 137 is no good 138 is
okay
um right and then 148 is okay
is that right oh my god 147 is no good
so we have some x's here and then and
then there's a large large region of
okay values
but but most of them are
um
you know
only forty percent of them survive
uh because of because of this test
then when we when we combine it with
this test
and we say that it also has to be an
ascii code plus 255 we get to throw in
lots more x's in this
in this row
and we find out that uh in fact
uh
uh there's only one
there's only you know x's are everywhere
except in one in one position
right okay
so
so uh
uh this way says then if we if we have a
week if we have a table of of uh
of of
possible
values of f we can
um
exclude lots of lots of them and then
maybe there's only going to be one left
and here was a case where we were able
to
to
to force it
now
um
uh so that's that's a
forcing by exhaustion principle
uh
which which combines with the other
principle that we were using sort of by
going going in
by implications but not by exhaustion i
mean one of the
one of the uh
the somehow this these these are these
are uh
two two uh i think uh
sort of
have to be sort of definitely different
uh
ideas one is a uh
is a lower bound kind of argument yeah
there's an upper bound kind of argument
or something like that uh the uh
and and uh
there probably are some some more
powerful things
in here now because
if we know that this is a u
let me see another thing that you know
is that that table has to be symmetrical
this table has to be symmetric
cool along the diagonal because if
something can be f of something then
you can
you've got the fact that okay
let's see
okay so you're saying that if f of 184
could be
138 then a f of 138 could be 184 and so
so you get to
you get to block out the uh
the things the other way too
all right
okay so uh well we're near the
um
the end of today and uh
uh
i think that
some experience in programming would be
valuable to go to go next and one of the
so the i guess the issues to think about
between
today and thursday that at least strike
me
are well uh
how to add interaction to this uh what
what kinds of
of
support do we want to provide to a man
sitting there in the terminal saying
uh
asking questions what kind of questions
do we want to be able to answer
um
and what uh
what kind of mechanisms are we going to
need for
updating our data structures that we use
to answer those questions so that's the
that's the uh the main the main thing
sitting there uh
and if everybody comes knowing the
the code by thursday then we'll
we'll uh discuss the answer but other to
the code but otherwise we'll wait until
everybody's got it because i don't want
to take that
that out of it
oh no he comes
he comes a week from thursday the 31st i
believe
yeah so so uh
yeah so
so uh let's think now next thing about
uh the kinds of data structures to have
in the program and how they could be
uh
updated
with respect to interaction i guess
that's the
that's the next thing
but does anyone else have anything to
add
right now
you got partners for this one
try to
what rich
no no not yet
okay well let's uh yeah look look up
i
found it difficult ever cooperating with
other people i know you know you never
trust anybody but yourself
uh
however um
you think so
well no i think the uh the the you know
it doesn't mean that uh that that you
that you don't get to do any of the fun
programming yourself but uh but the
but this but uh just uh just looking at
each other's
program looking at talking about ideas
and so on combining two the two sets of
ideas makes it
makes it better but also
i think there's some kind of
excitement about uh
about
okay some things you have to do alone i
know that there's been some people in my
life that i could
that i could work with in the same room
at the same time and we could both
continue getting good ideas others we
would we would talk to each other and
we'd all go away for a few hours and
come back again and say now look at this
and and uh
no there's no general pattern but uh i i
really think uh uh cooperation is is a
is a good thing to to do so
try to find a partner by thursday
okay see